in a year defined by flops from Roma to
jesse Smollett from vice to Russian
collusion the Academy still gives out
its top prizes to the leftist narrative
we will analyze the biggest fails of
2018 and early 2019
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
all right we've got to dole out the nosy
is the biggest prices for narrative
fails in 2018 and 2019
but first let's make a little money
honey with Lending Club oh if you are
carrying revolving debt that means you
are not paying off your card every month
and you could be paying thousands an
interest every year that you don't have
to with Lending Club you can consolidate
your debt or pay off credit cards with
one fixed monthly payment since 2007
Lending Club has helped millions of
people regain control of their finances
with affordable fixed-rate personal
loans no trips to the bank no high
interest credit cards just go to Lending
Club com tell them about yourself tell
them how much you want to borrow pick
the terms that are right for you if
you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion net dollars in loans issued
go to Lending Club comm slash Knowles
keno wles
check your eight minutes borrow up to 40
G's that's Lending Club dot-com /
Knowles Lending Club dot-com / Knowles
do not allow yourself to waste money be
caught up paying off high interest
credit cards when you could be managing
your finances a smarter way
check it out Lending Club com / Knowles
all loans made by Webb bank member FDIC
Equal Housing lender the the leftist
narrative is falling apart here from
politics up through the culture all the
way up through the left's religion which
is global warming and it's all happening
right now at the same time
coincidentally right at awards season
and we will get to the Oscars but first
we have got to get to the greatest scene
that I have seen in any medium film
television social media the greatest
scene of the whole year shockingly
unexpectedly care of Diane Feinstein
[Music]
okay I'll tell you what we have our own
green New Deal sciences
we have 12 years to turn this around
well it's not going to get turned around
in ten years what we can do one of the
people by the people and what's
interesting about this group it's I've
been doing this for thirty years I know
what I'm doing you come in here and you
say it has to be my way or the highway I
don't respond to that I've gotten
elected
I just ran I was elected by almost a
million vote plurality and I know what
I'm doing so you know maybe people
should listen a little bit I hear what
you're saying but where are the people
who voted you you're supposed to listen
to us that's your how old are you I
don't exchange devastating and it
actually only gets worse for those those
exploitative adults and that teenager
and those kids because dianne feinstein
doesn't miss a beat first of all the
girl is wrong the teenager is wrong she
says your job is to do exactly what we
tell you to do that's not true we have a
representative republic we don't have a
direct democracy it is not the job of
these people to do exactly according to
exact polling data 50% plus one of
people want this so we have to do it
that's not the purpose of a
congressional representative we elect
people to go to Congress for their
judgment and then they use their
judgment
regardless hopefully in the best case
scenario regardless of what public
opinion polls say but then Dianne
Feinstein won't even here it just goes
you know were the people who voted for
you how old are you well I'm 16 you
didn't vote for me boom done I love this
I mean this reminds me obviously of
Lindsey Graham 2.0 or Lindsey Graham Bo
we're seeing this with Dianne Feinstein
I don't know what her cool Sylvester
Stallone nickname is going to be but you
know we often hear oh the senators are
so old oh they're so old they can't pop
we need young blood younger but no uh-uh
with the minimum
four senators should be about 90 I think
I love this if older incumbent senators
are given us grambo and and new
Feinstein look yeah good have the
minimum age be a hundred and and
actually this this is a half serious
point because this is the leftist narrow
you know the left gets everything
backwards we talk about this all the
time and for the left children have
greater moral teaching authority than
adults for the you know in reality when
you're a little kid you think like a
little kid and then when you're a
teenager you think a little bit clearer
you of a little bit more access to
reason you've got a little bit more
education but you still basically know
nothing then you go to college you still
basically know nothing but you're
learning a little bit you're thinking a
little more deeply maybe in your 20s
you're formulating some ideas again not
a ton of experience of the world I'll be
the first to admit it I'm in my 20s
that's why I try to have a little bit of
awe and humility when it comes to the
the vast tradition when it comes to our
intricate system of politics as you get
older you increase in wisdom you grow in
wisdom that's a virtue of time for the
left they think it's exactly the
opposite they think that as people get
older they get stupider they get less
educated they become less wise they
become less mature I know this is by
definition not possible but the left
doesn't let itself get tied up with
silly little things like logic and and
the definitions of words so for the left
really a group of little children is the
font of wisdom this is why the left
exploits kids all the time when they're
not killing them on tables an hour after
they're born the left exploits children
immediately you saw this in the that
video during the election of all these
kids saying foul-mouthed language F this
F that they put them on camera to show
how fired up the little kids were you
see all the time they bring these kids
to the rallies they're you f Trump F
this then you say they bring them into
the office as though that what are these
kids know about global warming if we
were to be told that global warming is
settled science don't you think you'd
bring some scientists in rather than
little children they say stop
politicizing science and listen to these
little children
mmm that doesn't make a whole lot of
sense does it really shame on these
adults because they're doing - they're
exploiting the kids for one putting them
on camera when they shouldn't be on
camera making them famous when they when
they should know better than them to do
that and then they're terrifying these
kids I mean these kids very well might
believe that they're all gonna be dead
in 12 years these kids very well might
believe that global warming is going to
kill all of them within 12 years they're
terrifying these little kids for what
nobody's gonna be dead in 12 years
because of global warming not a nobody
ain't gonna happen
well let's make a bet right now any
amount of money you write it in put it
in in the comments write it in tweet at
me I'm happy to take that bet with
anybody of course no one would seriously
make that bet including these shameless
adults who are exploiting the kids
because it's not about protecting the
environment it's not about protecting
people it's never about protecting kids
it's about taking power it's about
implementing socialism that's why the
green new deal ostensibly about the
environments so urgent we have to do it
right now gives us socialist healthcare
or rebuilds every edifice in the country
has government takeovers of Industry has
a universal basic income for some why is
all that because it's all just about
seizing power for socialism now
alexandria cassia cortez did not like
this video of Dan Feinstein smacking
around these these exploited adults and
these kids so she for some reason
videotaped herself cooking again because
she's a serious person and she gave her
latest urgent plea for the green New
Deal a performance of the year our
planet is going a disaster if we don't
turn this ship around and so it's
basically like there's scientific
consensus that the lives of children are
going to be very difficult and it does
lead I think young people to have a
legitimate question you know should is
it okay to still have children and I
mean not just financially because people
are graduating with 20s
$100,000 for the student loan cat and so
they can't even afford to have kids in
the house but also just this basic moral
question like what do we do and and even
if you don't have kids there are still
children here in the world and we have a
moral obligation to them and to leave a
better world for them mmm that you of
course not to belabor the point but when
you have a sitting Democrat governor
calling for killing children after
they're born when you have another
Democrat governor calling for killing
children as they're being born and
taking away protections if they are
killed while they are being born if
they're murdered while they're being
born then you have to raise the question
how much does the left to really care
about children and listen this is the
mark that something has gone really
wicked in your politics this is always
the mark this is the mark throughout
history when you want to stop creating
children or be getting children when you
want to cut off life when you want to
cut off life at birth when you want to
cut off life at the end through
euthanasia doctor assisted suicide
legalizing suicide when you want there
to be fewer people when you say it's
moral for there to be fewer people when
you say we have overpopulation when you
say any number of excuses to squeeze off
human life that is the sign that your
politics has delved into something
wicked and that's what she's talking
about I've heard people say this they
say well we can't bring kids into this
world because the world is so terrible
there's so there's global warming and
then they say we can't bring kids into
this world because it'll cause global
warming which is it it's just it's a
conclusion looking for an argument and
that's that's us I don't know if
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes is even
remotely conscious enough to realize
that but she is being used by fairly
wicked ideologies and then she and then
she is using these ideologies in a
really manipulative way whenever
politicians say think of the children
you
that you were dealing with a demagogue
there was only one exception to this
which is when politicians are actually
calling for the slaughter of babies an
hour after they're born as is happening
now but when they talk in the abstract
say think of the children you are
dealing with a demagogue an AOC is
silent by the way on the killing of
children but that's what this is about
this is about demagoguery and it is
about exploiting and terrifying kids to
destroy our Republican system of
government which is what will happen
that's what the green New Deal does it
destroys our Republican system of
government and she makes this point even
more acutely she makes this point even
more on the nose but quickly because I
actually this video in particular the
last week or so has me doubting whether
AOC is actually a good politician I've
really defended her political chops I
think she's just taken a wrong turn
we'll get to why in a second but first
oh you know how much I love my purple
mattress you know this I talk about it
all the time purple mattress is unlike
any other mattress you've ever slept on
it is it's not quite a memory foam it's
not quite an innerspring it's this
unique type of mattress developed by a
rocket scientist it's it's both firm and
soft at the same time how is that
possible I can't really tell you it just
is I was very skeptical when I first
heard about purple mattress they sent me
one so I don't even know honestly if I
want to use this it's it's just a weird
sounding thing listen I I really should
try it it's gonna be a sponsor I should
try it
I it took one night and I was hooked I
love this mattress so much it is so by
far the greatest mattress I've ever
slept on I go on the road a lot you know
I give these speeches at colleges and I
the first thing I miss is my purple
mattress and then my wife no and that's
not true my I miss my wife first I miss
sleeping next to my butt but the
Purple's up there though you know the
purple is really close it's fabulous
hundred night risk-free trial if you're
not fully satisfied you can return your
mattress for a full refund back by
10-year warranty free shipping and
returns free and home set up an old
mattress removal you're gonna love it
right now my listeners we're gonna free
purple pillow with the purchase of a
mattress that is in addition to the
great free gifts they're offering
site-wide just tech
kofi fait two eight four eight eight
eight it's the only way to get this free
pillow text Kofi Fay Co V Fe Fe two
eight four eight eight eight that is co
the fe Fe two eight four eight eight
eight message and data rates may apply
I'm beginning to seriously doubt if a OC
is a good politician the reason so I'll
actually I'll just show you what started
to make me wonder and maybe you'll be
able to get it too in that a little bit
later in that exact same clip this idea
that if we just you know I've been
working on this for X amount of years
it's like not good enough like we need a
universal sense of urgency and people
are trying to like introduce
watered-down proposals that are frankly
going to kill us they're going to kill
us actually and it's not that they're
conservatives are gonna kill us
it's that Democrats who also ostensibly
believe in global warming who also are
trying to regulate industry to stop
certain types of pollution or whatever
that's probably not actually going to do
that but that's ostensibly the purpose
of it those politicians are the ones who
are gonna kill us Democrats are the ones
who are gonna kill us the left is what's
going to kill us according to Alexandria
Ocasio cortez dianne feinstein talking
to those kids she could have been
talking straight to alexandria cassio
cortez she said you know when you come
running in here you who know nothing you
who are perfectly ignorant come running
in here and you scream and you yell and
you say my way or the highway I don't
respond very well to that and it's not
just Dianne Feinstein it's not just
senators we the American people don't
respond very well to that when you come
in when you make by the way she has a
demonstrable record of egregious errors
she knows nothing
she doesn't even know how taxes work she
thought that a three billion dollar tax
incentive in her district was meant
meant that there was three billion
dollars sitting around that the city of
New York was just gonna hand over to
Amazon she doesn't know what taxes are
it's the main function of Congress might
raise money and spend money she doesn't
know that and she's coming in here and
saying I understand the world
I understand everything in the material
world I understand the most complex
system we can possibly even imagine on
earth and I can predict to the year when
that system and Y is going to end all of
human life and it's in a dozen years and
if you don't do exactly what I tell you
to do
you are evil and you're responsible for
the destruction of humanity that's what
she's saying
now she sounds here obviously in this
clip she doesn't sound smart this end um
and like like and teehee and like like
like like like blah blah blah blah it's
both inarticulate and ignorant but who
cares maybe that's good politics among
Millennials who talk like that too
maybe I don't think it is I don't talk
like that I don't think it's I don't
want to degrade myself to talk like that
and I don't think other people should
too but maybe it could be good politics
except I know I'm no longer certain that
she's this brilliant politician people
compare her to Trump they say AOC is
just like Trump they both speak in a
sort of lower-level manner in public
they both are very good at manipulating
the media they're both very good at
riling up their bases okay maybe except
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes is a
professional activist who was according
to voter records living with her parents
as recently as two and a half years ago
Donald Trump is a billionaire who's
built a ton of businesses who has
dominated the most difficult industries
in the world for 40 years television New
York real estate casinos politics
obviously he ran for one political
office and his whole life and he wanted
on the first try
the most powerful office in the history
of the world not much of a comparison
the other thing is a AOC is choosing
issues that are very unpopular open
borders 70% 80% tax rates spending 40
trillion dollars outlawing planes trains
and automobiles and knocking down
people's houses printing money out of
nowhere those are not popular issues
president Trump chooses popular issues
border security strong economy
job creation those are very popular
issues and now she's making this really
difficult play which is to alienate all
of her potential allies what allies does
she have her first action as an elected
congresswoman was to invade Nancy
Pelosi's office and protest about global
warming now she's going after Dianne
Feinstein no she's going after all that
she's really alienating a lot of allies
in you're seeing pushback now you're
seeing pushback from Democrats who are
realizing that democratic socialism as
they call it socialism in all of its
forms is probably not working this
narrative isn't doing very well among
the American people
the Democrats are realizing maybe
socialism is not a winning issue now you
hear Kamala Harris is changing her tune
she was calling for the abolition of our
entire health care system not one month
ago and now she's saying I'm not a
Democrat socialist who said I wasn't no
not me I'm coming no no no you
misunderstood I'm a semuc rat no
Sheila's don't know now you heard it was
a mistake no no no I'm just a
progressive is what she's now saying
she's changing her tune and Kamala
Harris by the way is the weather vane of
2020 she's probably leading the pack
right now she has the most similarities
to Hillary even that horrific laughs and
she has the most to lose so she's really
plain it Barry said no I want to abolish
the US health care system no no I didn't
really mean that I'm embracing the
policies of democratic socialism huh no
no I didn't didn't really mean that
she's the weather Ben so you watch her
to see where the field is shaking out a
lot of polls show that Americans are
warming up to socialism and this is this
is certainly true among Democrats and
Millennials Democrats and Millennials
but I repeat myself have a warmer view
of socialism than they do of capitalism
and so the polls shows this Gallup shows
us this I'm not so sure it's happening
in real life and I think the evidence of
this is Camilla Harris the evidence of
this is not just Camilla Harris by the
way not only are the candidates backing
off even the DNC chairman Tom Perez who
said that Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
Democrat socialist is quote the future
of our part
listen to how he's talking about
socialism now how do you defend against
president Trump's charge in an effort to
portray the Democratic Party your tax
and spend policies as socialists this is
one of the oldest tricks in the PlayBook
Chris you go back 75 years when
Republicans don't want to discuss the
issues that matter to real people they
call it socialism Social Security when
it was being debated you had Republicans
calling it socialism the minimum wage in
1938 you had Republicans calling it
socialism Medicare Ronald Reagan said
and I quote Medicare will lead to
socialized medicine Medicare will lead
to socialism in America the Affordable
Care Act the children's health insurance
and program all of those things were
socialism socialism why do they do that
because they're wrong on the issues they
don't want to talk about pre-existing
conditions we're right on that issue we
want to make sure if you're diabetic you
can keep your coverage they don't want
to so they change the subject okay they
do talk about projection you just
changed the subject Chris Wallace asked
you how you're going to defend against
charges of socialism you called a
socialist the future of your party your
darling of the Democrat congressman is a
self-described socialist one of the
leaders of the pack for the presidential
race at least on paper I don't think
he'll really win is a self-described
socialist there were 40 candidates run
over 40 candidates in 2018 running as
Democrats with the backing of the
Democratic socialists you had candidates
all across the country embraced
socialism and now every presidential
candidate for the Democrats is embracing
the green New Deal which is by
definition socialism it's the government
taking over industries it's the
government tacit Act put instituting tax
rates of 7080 percent it's the
government printing money out of nowhere
40 trillion dollars of costs taxing
people and they can't tax any more they
just pull the money out of thin air
you're the one who's using the word
socialism and then you have to change
the subject because you can't defend it
see so he says well you know Republicans
are always calling us socialist no no no
you're calling yourself socialist and
then you realized that that's not a
winning strategy so you're trying to
pretend that you didn't but you did and
you all
and by the way he uses this example he
says you know Reagan said Medicare would
lead to socialism
show me the lie Reagan was exactly right
in fact the socialist health care policy
that is now being advocated by virtually
every Democrat presidential candidate I
actually I think all of them is called
Medicare for all it is saying oh yeah
that Medicare was a pretty good place
line for socialism so now we're going to
apply that to everybody and then we'll
have full socialist health care now look
we have to be grateful this is a good
sign that this is cracking up in the old
days Democrats would lie and they would
say we're no we're not really socialists
then within the last two years they've
said no no no we are socialist socialism
is a good word and now it's swinging
back again this mhm maybe that was a
little too bold
maybe we revealed ourselves a little too
much maybe that narrative is running up
against reality and nowhere is the
left-wing narrative running up against
reality more than in the Russia
collusion hoax Adam Schiff the biggest
spokesman for this this non traversée is
now bei all but admitting them CNN all
but admitting collusion didn't really
happen they're setting the stage for the
next scene we will get to that and then
we will get to the literal narratives
that are breaking apart in the terrible
movies of 2018 the awards shows the
Spirit Awards the Oscars and why Roma is
is shut why it's getting all of this
height even though it's a simply
terrible movie that I actually watched
this morning but first tonight
tune in to our next episode of daily
wire backstage where we will be talking
about everyone's favorite award show
daily wire god-king Jeremy boring Ben
Shapiro Andrew Klavan Alicia Kraus and a
lil owe me will be smoking stogies
drinking whiskey and laughing at the
dumpster fire known as Hollywood's most
important night as always only daily
wire subscribers get to ask the
questions so make sure to subscribe
today ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
Android clave and show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the map well show
you have to ask questions and the
mailbag coming up on Thursday
you get to ask questions backstage you
get another Kingdom you get a ton of
stuff and you get this
even I took the lid off so I could get
an even better mmm that's is the smell
of narratives breaking down that's what
it sounds like all culminating on the
night that celebrates narratives the
Oscars we will get to all of it in just
a second make sure you have your tumbler
ready we will be right back nowhere has
a leftist narrative flopped more than on
the Russia collusion hoax
here is Adam Schiff of obviously current
Democrat hack speaking to George
Stephanopoulos who pretends he's not a
Democrat hack now George Stephanopoulos
chief political guy over at ABC News
Network news George Stephanopoulos is a
career Democrat operative he was the
communications director for the Clintons
in the White House and here they're
speaking oh it's just just two
congressmen talking to a journalist even
Schiff is spinning his wheels because
the Russia collusion narrative is
falling apart do you have any evidence
at all that the president colluded
George's ample evidence of collusion of
the campaign and it's very much in the
public record and it's everything from
what we have seen recently about Paul
Manafort meeting with someone linked to
Russian intelligence and sharing polling
data and not top-line data not this is
why we think Trump is going to win data
but raw data complicated data we've seen
evidence of Roger stone in communication
with WikiLeaks we've seen the
president's son having a secret meeting
at Trump Tower that was presented to him
as part of the Russian government's
effort to help the Trump campaign his
acceptance of that help is interest in
getting that all of this is evidence of
collusion and there's much much more
weather that will amount to a criminal
conspiracy that can be proved beyond a
reasonable doubt we will have to wait
for Bob Muller to tell us but to to not
see what is plainly in front of us means
you you basically don't want to see the
evidence of collusion because is quite
abundant in a sense Adam Schiff is right
to not see all of the
that is plainly in front of us the
evidence of collusion which is abundant
is absurd and there is a lot of evidence
in front of us we know for a fact that
the Democrat Party and the Hillary
Clinton campaign and the Obama DOJ
colluded with foreign intelligence
specifically Russian that evidence is
called the steel dossier we know it
happened
we know that the Democrats and the
Hillary campaign paid fusion GPS to use
a foreign intelligence analyst to use
intelligence contacts in Russia to
compile the steel dossier which was then
passed along to the Obama DOJ it was
used as a pretext a flim flimsy pretext
to spy on the Trump campaign we know
that that collusion happened that is in
the public record that is the only
evidence of collusion that we have it's
not collusion between Trump and Russia
it's evidence of collusion between the
Democrats and the federal government and
Russia now Adam Schiff you see how he
shifts there at the end he says now
whether that will will lead to criminal
conspiracies right know that we don't
know I win or not so sure about that hmm
okay you're kind of moving the goal
posts here I thought we had two years of
investigations because you were gonna
throw Trump in the clink you were gonna
there was some crime that was committed
there's no crime that was committed why
are we investigating this at all and
it's really not looking good for Schiff
the Senate Intelligence Committee
concluded its investigation on Russian
collusion no evidence of any nefarious
activities between Trump and Russia
that's not just according to the
Republicans on the committee that's
according to the Democrats as well we
have Bob Muller just today released an
800 page report on Paul Manafort I
haven't gotten to read the whole report
yet just happened before the show
according to an analysis of that report
there is no mention of trump or
collusion or Russia there's no evidence
there's nothing in that report you would
expect if collusion were real if this
hoax were real if it were to be
found it would be found in the manna
fort file manna for twas the link
remember manna Ford had all these shady
connections to Russia and Russian
interests in Ukraine and he was brought
in by Trump to collude with her remember
all that but it's not in the manna for
word where else would it be maybe in
Roger stone are they getting Roger stone
on colluding with Russia no here's even
CNN admitting this if a collusion
conspiracy case is to be made you'd
think that Roger stone would factor in
it but he wasn't indicted for that he
was indicted for these so-called
processed crimes you can say okay well
the feds can charge successively but now
comes word that Muller is finishing up
so doesn't the absence of additional
indictments against stone suggest as the
president would say no collusion what
does I mean you have to you know call
them as you see them there is no
evidence thus far of collusion between
the Trump campaign or President Trump
and the Russians in hacking these
computer systems and moreover it's it's
really quite unlikely right which if you
were a KGB spymaster would you really
collude with Donald Trump and put
yourself one tweet away from destruction
on perhaps the most secret operation and
it's it's recent history of course it's
laughable it was always laughable that's
why I've been referring to it as boris
and Natasha Rocky and Bullwinkle it's
cartoonish the image that they presented
of Donald Trump and the Russian
government now CNN is admitting that
this they're starting to shift they have
to shift because this Mulder report is
going to come out the indictments
against man afford for whatever buying
nice suits in the 90s this these
indictments against Roger stone for I
don't know telling some lie at some
point in his life which he brags about
doing that it's gonna come out and then
you're gonna see that Donald Trump is
not boris and Natasha
and then they're gonna have egg on their
face so they're starting to pivot now
Schiff is trying to pivot now he's
saying oh well no no no the the very
fact that Donald Trump's jeff Sessions
talked to a Russian once on the
there's just there is evidence it's just
it's out there as we all know it it's
out there forget don't pay no attention
to the man behind the curtain in a
broader sense the greatest obstacle for
conservatives is the people are
constantly trying to screw everything up
we have something good going but nothing
gold can stay nature's first green is
gold her hardest you to hold her early
Leafs a flower but only so an hour then
Eden then to leave subsides to leave so
Eden sank to grief so dawn Goes Down
today nothing gold can stay as Robert
Frost said that that constant churning
of innovation constant churning of
progress is frustrating to conservatives
because people are always messing up a
good thing and they don't know a good
thing when they see it the greatest
advantage to conservative is that
reality reasserts itself eventually this
is why Russell Kirk didn't name his book
the conservative mind he didn't call it
the conservative route which he
initially wanted to because it might be
a route in the short term but reality
reasserts itself this is the ultimate
political hope and cause of hope for
conservatives and that's what we're
seeing now reality is reasserting itself
two years later two years of these
investigations two years wish Adam
Schiff babbling around the Senate
Intelligence Committee the Peter struck
Lisa Paige Andy McCabe Paul Bob Muller
all the investigations but eventually
you got to put up or shut up eventually
reality reasserts itself and so what
that's gonna do it's already doing it I
guess is cause a major credibility
problem for Democrats they have a major
credibility issue now it's kind of like
when presidents bet on the economy
President Trump has done this sometimes
they say look at how great the economy
is doing see the economy is doing really
well so I'm a good president but
eventually just by the nature of
economic cycles eventually the economy
is going to collapse that's it's a
similar thing when Democrats say look at
the fantasy look at the narrative we've
created see see the narrative is
internally consistency believe believe
the narrative you can't rely on fantasy
forever
and then you've got egg on your face
and then you've got no credibility it's
not just shift with the credibility
problem it's all of them Harry Reid
former Senate Majority Leader shameless
Democrat Harry Reid is now saying did an
interview he said Trump is not doing
anything right he's just so awful that
he doesn't get credit for anything he's
just everything he's done is terrible
he misses George Bush he says oh he
misses the days of George Bush he says a
Donald Trump era he says in hindsight I
wish every day for a George Bush again
he says Bush was like Babe Ruth compared
to President Donald Trump he and I had
our differences but no one ever
questioned his patriotism except for
Harry Reid who did question his
patriotism himself he said President
Bush is a liar he betrayed Nevada and he
betrayed the country he said the man's
father is a wonderful human being I
think this guy's a loser
he said Bush was the worst president of
America ever betrayed his country that's
what he says now what the left is
relying on is that we have short
memories maybe we do but you'll get
reminded of this this will come back
reality will reassert itself they said
all the same things about George Bush
they said all the same things about
Ronald Reagan reality comes back again
and again we're seeing reality come back
now even you know this was this is so
amazing
even for Reid Zakaria far-left CNN
commentator even he is making this point
about what he calls the Democrats
dreamworld
in their zeal to match the sweeping
rhetoric of right-wing populism
Democrats are spinning out dramatic
proposals indeed but in which facts are
sometimes misrepresented the numbers
occasionally don't add up an emotional
appeal tends to trump actual policy
analysis that's right that is what's
happened he's trying to say all the
right always does this but the left
shouldn't do this of course it's the
opposite the right doesn't really did
the right does it sometimes but not much
the right has a lot of inner controls
that stop it from going too far into
Fantasyland for one a lot of different
competing philosophies and ideologies on
the
keep people in check on the left it's
only progressivism leading toward
socialism and even Fareed Zakaria is
recognizing this problem this is a big
flop this is a narrative cracking up
it's cracking up right around the Oscars
as good a time as any of her narratives
to crack up it's not just happening in
politics it is happening in show
business too there this influx of
socialism now even communism on the Left
the this was reflected in the culture
this year maybe it was caused by the
culture boots Riley he did this movie
sorry to bother you I said it was one of
the worst movies I've ever seen in it
and it is sorry to bother you is a
communist movie boots Riley the guy
who's made the movie is a communist
filmmaker and outspoken communist he's
been a member of the Communist Party I
think since he was 15
everybody's going in and out but he was
attracted to it since he was a young man
boots
Riley cannot admit he's the great
example of this he can admit that his
fantasies are not jiving with reality
this is why sorry to bother you isn't a
good movie why it's a thin movie as a
shallow movie it's a cheap movie because
it just it's to its doctrinaire its
dogmatic it doesn't actually speak to
the human condition here is boots riley
not at the Oscars but at the IFC Spirit
Awards the Independent Film Awards
giving his acceptance speech and
defending the dictatorship starving its
people and killing its people in
Venezuela look at how far ideologies
this guy astray so want to say that the
CIA is trying to have a coup in
Venezuela I haven't been watching the
what since I've been here so they might
be doing it right now and we should all
be putting our voices out to stop the us
from having regime change for oil in
Venezuela
[Applause]
he's defending a brutal socialist
dictator who is now killing his own
people who has starved his people for
well over a year what is it two years
now and a regime a socialist regime that
took one of the wealthiest countries in
the world and destroyed its economy
destroyed its people took even an
oil-rich nation and rekted people eating
rats in the street and this guy is
defending them this guy is saying no no
forget about those starving people no no
forget about reality no no we have to
defend the ideology that is starving
them because that's how committed he is
to the narrative that's why his movies
are terrible and it's why his politics
are terrible even Bernie Sanders even
the macdaddy socialist in the United
States admits that socialism has failed
in Venezuela he tweeted this out today
said quote the people of Venezuela are
enduring a serious humanitarian crisis
the Maduro government must put the needs
of its people first allow humanitarian
aid into the country and refrain from
violence against protesters he Bernie
Sanders also defends Maduro but even
Bernie is admitting tacitly implicitly
that socialism has failed in Venezuela
and the Oscars are a victim of the
leftist fantasy to the Oscars award
shows nobody's watching it people are
tuning out people are trying to stop
these crazy political speeches and
actually they did a better job this year
I I did watch the Oscars very few people
watch the Oscars I was one of them they
had no host it wasn't oh it was all kind
of shallow left to stuff bad movies
Spike Lee was basically the only one who
was able to sneak a political speech in
there here he is
the word today is irony the date the
24th the month February which also
happens to be the shortest month of the
year which old happens to be Black
History Month the year 2019 the year
1619 history herstory 1619 2019 400
years come again
[Laughter]
Spike Lee doing the worst free
association slam poetry I've ever heard
Spike Lee doing his Rain Man impression
there at the Oz feed 16 20 22 20 22 + 5
27 27 had the numbers done it's 9 9 9
took nob not it's not a Dustin Hoffman
did it better then Spike Lee did he goes
on he goes on after he does weird free
association with numbers he goes on on
what should be the biggest night of his
life a director who is not a good film
if Spike Lee is not a good filmmaker and
yet he's made himself into this
political figure so they felt they had
to give him an Oscar he got a pity Oscar
he got a participation trophy he should
be grateful he should be thankful and
what does he do he complains about
everything he's complaining about the
month length of the month of February
he's complaining that it's some racist
conspiracy that February only has 28
days 30 days have September April June
and November
and when short February's done all the
rest have 31 because of racism or
something he goes on to rant about other
things for years our answer was stolen
from other Africa and brought the
Jamestown Virginia enslaved our ass has
worked from the land from can't see in
the morning they can't see at night my
grandmother's name is Sheldon Rita who
live be honey is young who was a
Spellman college graduate even though
her mother was a slave my grandma who
saved 50 years of Social Security checks
to put her first grandchild
she called me spikey Pooh she put me
through Morehouse College and NYU grad
film NYU
before the world tonight I get praise or
ancestors well built this country and
was today along with the genocide of his
native people how about you first of all
the genocide of the native peed on have
enough time for me to get into all of
the nonsense in that speech but how
about just to start out how about you
thank the country that freed the slaves
how about you thank the country that is
so great that it could give an Oscar it
could make a world-famous guy out of the
great grandson of a slave that the
daughter of a slave could go to college
that that woman could then put her
grandson through a very expensive Film
School
unfortunately because he clearly didn't
learned very much at that film school
because he's not a very good filmmaker
and then they could give that kid a pity
trophy because he whined enough and they
felt bad for him so they gave him an
Oscar how about you say thank you is the
best night of your life and all you can
do is whine and complain you're
resilient heir who is not even really
talented is not even a really skilled
filmmaker you still became a zillionaire
you're you're handing gold trophies to
one another you're receiving a gold
trophy you've lived with the greatest
material success of virtually anybody in
all of the history of the world say
thank you but they can't say thank you
because of the narrative the left cannot
say thank you because of the narrative
now the Oscar is broadly we only have a
couple minutes left it basically this
was a better year for the Oscars than
most why the movies were worse than most
years the movies were all pretty
dreadful there were some good
performances out there rami malek Olivia
Colman were good performances rami malek
as Freddie Mercury and put me in
Rhapsody did a good job Olivia Colman
did a great job in the favorite both
movie is kind of whatever but but the
performances were good Roma did a one
best foreign film and one or two other
awards too it did not take a home Best
Picture I did we had won Best Director I
watched it this morning because this was
the favorite this was the it's a movie
supposed to be a masterpiece
it's about a Mexican housekeeper and
it's shot in black and white and it's
really long and there's not a lot of
dialogue and nothing really happens and
but it's really so profound and so I
decided to watch it this morning because
I didn't want to knock it without
watching it obviously Romo is everything
that's wrong with the Oscars it's Romo
is everything that's wrong with the film
industry Romo is everything that's wrong
with the left's politics politics is
down of culture we should expect this
Romo is self-indulgent tripe
they say that nostalgia is history after
a few drinks this whole movie is just
totally self-indulgent totally
pretentious nostalgia it reminds I think
the reason people like it or pretend to
like it is because it's people who have
never seen a good film and they think
that this is what a good film is
supposed to look like you know it's in
black and white and it's really long and
it's really slow and it's dimension it's
in black and white and it's and it's a 4
in and it's in foreign languages it's
pretentious it's uncultured and it's
pointless
much like the left a Ross Douthat and
National Review points that the film is
actually quite bourgeois the whole point
of the film spoiler alert but who cares
is that a housekeeper who was working
for a basically rich family which is the
family of the filmmaker that she
dedicates her whole life to serving them
and that that's a good thing it's a
fairly bourgeois it's not a terribly
radical movie in that way but because
it's got the patina of intersectionality
progressives like it a roast out that
says if the movie were about an upper
middle-class white family and it's black
servants in suburbia in America there
would be very problematic wouldn't it if
the point of the film was that the black
servant should serve the white family
and that's a great thing
that I probably that movie wouldn't win
an Oscar but Netflix very very cleverly
made it intersectionally appropriate now
we all have to pretend that it's good
this can't go on forever there is a cost
to a shallow culture that the we have
this present bias where we think
everything now is good everything old is
bad
no better we are better than all the
old-timey people it's what angsty
teenagers think Spike Lee is an angsty
teenager Oh everything before us was
terrible it was all bad now we're
finally maybe doing something good dad
doesn't know anything the trouble is the
longer this persists the harder it will
be to recover the wisdom of the ages the
harder it will be to make a good movie
it was the last time we made a good
movie when was the last time we had a
good innovation in politics the longer
we allowed this lack of culture this
lack of education this lack of
seriousness this ingratitude there's a
lack of humility this pride to persist
the harder it will be if not impossible
to recover the wisdom of the ages in our
religion in our culture and in our
politics that's the that's the message
now the narrative is breaking up a
little bit and a word seized and that's
good but what comes next we can dread or
we can hope for for something better in
the future but we're going to have to
take it seriously from religion to
culture to politics and are we capable
of that I'm not so sure we'll have to
find out check out backstage what are we
talking about the Oscars again
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Miller I'll see you later
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19